les américains ont l'idéologie de leur
géographie c'est à dire qu'ils ont pas
d'abord commencé par avoir des
idéologies qu'ils ont qu'ensuite ils ont
mises en oeuvre je pense que l'idéologie
qui l'on est le résultat de ce que sont
les états unis et les états unis c'est
quoi c'est une terre de liberté pour des
colons venant d'europe qui étaient pour
une large part oppressé c'est un endroit
c'est dolan of plenty enfin je veux dire
c'est l'endroit où on a tout ce qu'on
veut à profusion donc il ya de l'or des
bisons des forêts des terres cultivables
des fruits des arbres
enfin je veux dire no limits quoi ces
voix là et donc les états unis ils ont
fait un peuple à cette image
du reste le système politique américain
est le système le moins contraignant qui
soient ses terres que l'état fédéral aux
états unis on lui a donné trois 3
mandats sécuritaire c'est déjà sur la
sécurité intérieure
donc tous les gens vous adorez le russie
noah cia et le fbi et c'est donc des
gens qui s'occupent de la sécurité
intérieure je m'occupe de la sécurité
extérieure l'armée et je m'occupe de la
sécurité économique c'est-à-dire la
madeleine et puis pour le reste surtout
que je ne m'occupe de rien voilà donc le
mandat qu'on a donné à l'état fédéral
aux etats-unis c'est surtout d'autres
s'occuper de rien et c'est à l'image de
ce qu'elle pays où les ressources sont
tellement abondante que chacun porte
avec lui le credo qui peut se
débrouiller tout seul parce qu'il peut
avoir accès tout seul le colon est venue
du fait qu'il y avait plein de choses
plein de ressources suffisait juste de
tuer quelques audiences mais à part ça
il y avait tout ce qu'on voulait donc le
l'américain il a fait un système qui est
à son image et donc il a fait une
idéologie qui était à l'image de ce qui
était physiquement les etats unis c'est
bien dans ce sens là que les choses se
sont passées la propagation de
l'american way of life par exemple aux
chinois savoir quelles implications sur
monde entier alors l'american way of
life comme je le disais c'est transposer
ailleurs le fait qu'on est dans un monde
sans limites puisque c'était ça
physiquement
l'univers dans lequel l'américain a
évolué a bien évidemment le monde n'est
pas sans limites le monde a des limites
il a des limites partout sauf que les
etats-unis les ont touchés plus tard que
les autres
en europe on avait touché les limites
avant l'europe était plus densément
peuplées on a achevé la déforestation en
europe en 1850
on avait déjà en europe dans certains
endroits des problèmes d'accès aux
ressources naturelles donc l'american
way of life ça a été les limites
arrivent plus tard elles sont elles sont
plus loin il faut savoir par exemple
qu'en 1939 70 % de la production
mondiale de pétrole était américaine
donc ça l'europe et avait déjà elle
passait son pic d'extraction de charbon
en grand-bretagne pardon et en france
nommé grande bretagne donc le donc le
l'american way of life exporté ailleurs
ça veut dire faites comme nous utiliser
toutes les ressources que vous arrivez à
trouver sans vous imposer de limites et
évidemment que ça butera plus vite
ailleurs que chez eux alors en chine
ils ont ils au niveau ils en ont profité
on va dire pendant 30 ans commence déjà
à buter sur des limites ce qui se
rabattent un peu sur la mer de chine
nommé lors qu'auront 7 ou 9 stress et ça
c'est le cas on ne ferait alors moi je
ne suis pas un spécialiste de la
géopolitique chinoise par contre ce que
je suis capable de dire c'est que comme
le carburant de l'économie industrielle
c'est l'énergie
les chinois aujourd'hui ils sont déjà
pas très loin d'être en butée sur leur
croissance leur approvisionnement
pétrolier n'augmente plus à la vitesse à
laquelle il augmentait jusqu'à
maintenant il ya des questions qui
commencent à se poser sur leur
approvisionnement charbonnier les
tendances sont trop enfin c'est sur un
nombre d'années trop court pour que l'on
puisse commencer en tirer des
conclusions
par contre il commence vraiment à avoir
des caisses d des problèmes sur la
quantité de terres cultivables et sur
les rendements agricoles
donc ils commencent à arriver eux aussi
en butée et s'est pas totalement un
hasard pour moi si les chinois sont en
train de s'emparer très fortement de la
question environnementale
parce que je pense qu'ils sont vraiment
en train de se rendre compte
qu'ils sont à venir la croissance
chinoise à deux chiffres et même à un
chiffre je pense pas qu'elle va
continuer pendant 20 ans